This course is meant to tell the stories our genomes hold for us,
both known and unknown. Now, depending on
your perspective this can mean different things.
>> The lessons here will cover what genomes are and how they work.
We'll learn how genetic information changes over time, and how it's passed down.
>> We'll learn about how some traits
are controlled by few genes and other traits
are controlled by many genes. Genes. Ultimately,
we'll see how we can use genetics to
trace our past and see how we're all
connected, all the while, we'll be getting first hand
accounts about certain traits and learning about the
social implications of knowing the genetic information underlying them.
By the end of this course, you'll have
a solid grasp of genetic information. And how it's
organized into a genome and affects a myriad of
traits. So get ready for tales from the genome.